Okay, the next thing we're going to do, is add
let's replace our dictionary cache in ASCII Chan with
memcached. Okay, here we are in ASCII Chan. fortunately,
memcached is, there's a, there's a version built into the
App Engine that you run on your local machine,
so you can develop against it. And then when
you deploy your machine on App Engine, Google has
memcache already spread out for you across many machines and
you don't have to deal with it. So, that's a very
nice convenience. First what we do, is we import it which is
just, it's in the Google App Engine API memcache. So we
do that. And now let's replace our dictionary cache with memcache. Which
should be pretty straightforward, since the two behave very similarly. Okay,
the first thing we could get rid of is this cache line,
we don't need that any more. So, we got rid of
our cache dictionary, let's use the memcache library now. Now, this syntax
here, key in CACHE, and all that stuff, is specific
to Python dictionaries, so we need to get rid of
that. Instead let's try to look up arts up out
of memcache. So it is going to be arts equals
memcache.get key. In memchache in the official protocol, both keys
and values need to be strings. In this library values
can be Python DataTypes in the Memcache library. That Google
provides, we'll convert your Python Data Type into a string.
And then when you fetch the data out of the cache, it
will convert it back into your Python Data Type. So we can
still store our our objects directly in the CACHE but the keys
need to be strings and so we're going to use top as our
key. Now, we're going to change this if statement a little bit because
now, we just looked up arts out of memCache. And if it's
not in the cache Arts will be none. So let's structure this
like so; If Arts is none or update, round the query and
we don't need that other line. Now, so the
query doesn't change, we need to change this line to
set the key in the Cache. Which is memCache.set key,
arts and that should do it. Okay, so let's go
ahead and try this out on our browser we,
we're in our page now. If I reload this page,
we can go to our terminal and we can see
that we ran a DB query on our GET request,
and if we were to run another, if we were
to reload that page again, I reloaded it. You would
see that moved onto a DB Query, pretty cool huh.
I want to show you something built in the App Engine
is an Admin tool. If you are running App Engine
you can go _aah/admin/memcache. You can actually view the memcache thing,
if I reload this page, it says we have one
item in our Cache. If I were to click Flush Cache,
we can actually clear the Cache and if I were to
reload this page and then check out our console. You can see
that we ran a database query again, and if I go back
to our page here and reload it, we can see that we
have one item in our Cache, cause we just loaded it. This
is kind of neat you can type in a, a k, key here
and click Display and it'll show you the value, in that Cache.
And in this case it as top is pickled. Pickled is the,
Python library for converting a Python Object in to a string. And
then the Google memcache library is automatically doing that for us. So,
yeah pretty neat handy tool here. If you want to test your
caching you can sit here and flush it and you can see how
many items are in the Cache and manipulate it that way. Anyway
that's how you implement ad memcache to your App. Once you understand the
algorithm for caching, you know check the Cache, return the value, hit
the deviant. You know that sort of thing, using memcache is a sinch.